yeah welcome to this video playing lot
back with that no name pretty in pretty
new account well let's say not a very
frequent icon with many games and yeah
you won game is missing actually I am
screwed up the recording before that for
the I didn't really know what I did
there but somehow I didn't have the
board it was kind of kind of firm yeah
off for a couple of centimeters was a
bit weird and it was a bit of a shame
that I didn't get that game on video
properly because it was one of those
super dirty cases where one where my
opponent um just played a completely
terrible game and then avoided all kinds
of drawers and just wanted to win on
time which he managed barely with one
point left or so so as one of those
games that really show you that the
other side is a complete [ __ ] but I
couldn't upload that set at screwed up
the screen so let's see the Smith Mora
here he actually allowed Bishop g4 which
I forgot to play what normally goes age
3 here early on somehow he did not play
that oh he's taking lots of time
lot back mean anything couldn't be three
what kind of moves that ok.let that's
that's very strange does not belong into
this position at all and 4 997 c5
yeah I want to go to civil anyway and
the Queen I mean you normally try to
complete this maroc see bite with some
pawn to be three
I don't know set a computer he's playing
very slow for a computer it seems very
strange for a human player of that level
okay let's see what happens
my plan is Bishop g4 if possible taking
on f3 yeah he's actually not doing
anything against it and then placing a
piece on deform
okay clearing the default
maybe I should really take them before
he actually recognizes that he should
avoid that trade so I would like to
trade dark squared Bishop sand then put
the knight on d4 that would be the most
the most promising scenario but I'm not
sure that I'm able to get that night 94
I already could have played earlier
which gives gives black an advantage but
it's a maybe not the best way to do it
yeah we should be five Bishop takes age
6 s probably not can I don't know should
I avoid that or not the move the queen
is got be five that's not very good okay
but that's not idea maybe Bishop f4 was
something that I should have prevented
so let's go here and try to play 96
again
cats don't get the dark oh don't get
them trade at the dark squid bishops
somehow I don't get that done so let's
get this off
who is not playing rook takes the one
immediately I don't know
white resigns what a mysterious game
yeah what a mysterious game sticking
ages playing somewhat thought we had
moves but it also probably wasn't a
computer I don't know it was a biet game
I don't get it really okay um yeah that
that's a slight slightly inaccurate you
should go h3 first I forgot to do that
it's not bad to take that night but okay
I forgot about that now I cannot do it
because that'd be seven is hanging will
be three is a very strange move whatever
it does simply does not fit into this
into this kind of structure at 97 night
a 40 yeah here Black is somewhat better
because of that weakness age 6 p-6 or I
think all normal there was some
alternative certainly our rookie one is
also somewhat mysterious ticks yeah
maybe I should just go nitey form I mean
that was possible just installing that
dominating bishop maybe that's the best
way to play that Bishop is much stronger
than the bishop one of three but okay
it's I still was hoping for that
scenario where we trade bishops and I
get the night to deform it Bishop f4 was
preventing that here Jim I'm all the way
better to run up to the up to the final
position but it's nothing great I mean
it's not like I'm winning his Bishop is
bad but it's I mean I don't know the
time
would have been an issue but still weird
that you just resigned yeah that a very
mysterious game okay thanks for watching